غزه من رفح مراسل الجزيره هشام زقوت
ومسلسل الاستهدافات ايضا في رفح ل سيمه
للسيارات المدنيه مستمر
هشام بالفعل في رفح في خانيونس في هذه
المناطق وايضا في المنطقه الوسطى جميعها
هذه المناطق تتعرض الى قصف عنيف من
الطائرات وكذلك من المدفعيه الاسرائيليه
طائره مسيره اطلقت باتجاه سياره مدنيه
طائرات الاف 16 قصفت منزلا في رفح صباح
هذا اليوم ايضا الان الاليات والجيش
الاسرائيلي ينسف عده منازل في في منطقه
معن في خانيونس كذلك هناك عده استهدافات
في في المناطق الشرقيه الجنوبيه لمدينه
خانيونس منطقه قيزان النجار منطقه البطن
السمين اذا هي عمليات قصف متواصله
ومتتاليه منذ منتصف ليل هذه هذا اليوم
ونحن نشهد ونرصد عده استهدافات من قبل
الجيش الاسرائيلي وجل هذه الاستهدافات على
منازل مدنيه على سيارات مدنيه على
المواطنين في اكثر من منطقه طائرات
استطلاع تستهدف هؤلاء المواطنين وبالاخص
النازحين الذين يحاولون الخروج من المناطق
التي تتعرض الى قصف عنيف من الطائرات من
المدفعيه ويحاولون الخروج الى مناطق اكثر
امنا يبحثون عن الامن والامان لكن يلاحقهم
القصف الاسرائيلي حتى وهم ذاهبون الى تلك
المناطق وبالتالي الجيش الاسرا ي كثف خلال
على الاقل الساعه الماضيه من عملياته في
مناطق خانيونس ايضا في المنطقه الوسطى في
خانيونس القصف الاسرائيلي مركز على ثلاث
مناطق اساسيه هي المناطق التي تقع في جنوب
وشرق جنوب شرق مدينه خانيونس منطقه بطن
السمين ومنطقه جورت اللوت وايضا منطقه
قزان النجار وهذه المناطق باتت تستهدف من
قبل الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه من قبل
المدفعيه الاسرائيليه القصف متواصل هناك
عده عائلات ما زالت محاصره في تلك المناطق
بالاضافه الى منطقه معن التي بدا الجيش
الاسرائيلي على ما يبدو نسمع اصوات
انفجارات عنيفه او يسمع شهود العيان اصوات
انفجارات عنيفه ناجمه على ما يبدو عن نسف
الجيش الاسرائيلي لعده منازل في تلك
المنطقه شهود عيان يعني ينظرون ويبصرون
تلك المنطقه ويقولون ان اصوات الانفجارات
ناجمه عن اصوات انفجارات ناجمه عن قصف
واستهداف هذه المنازل وتفجيرها على ما
يبدو من قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي هذه
المناطق تتعرض الى قصف عنيف بالاضافه الى
المنطقه الوسطى ايضا مخيم المغازي مخيم
البريج وكذلك المناطق الشرقيه لدير البلح
قريه المصدر كذلك كلها تتعرض الى قصف عنيف
قبل قليل كان هناك عده استهدافات ايضا في
مخيم النصيرات وكذلك في المناطق الشرقيه
لدير البلح وكل هذه الاستهدافات متواصله
ومستمره وهذا بالتاكيد هو ضمن المسلسل
الاسرائيلي بقصف المنازل المدنيه كان
الجيش الاسرائيلي توغل وانسحب من عده
مناطق اعاد التمركز في منطقه شرق دير
البلح الى السياج الفاصل عادت الدبابات
والاليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه مخيم
المغازي ايضا انسحبت منه الدبابات
العسكريه قبل يومين اعادت اليوم
وبالامس اعاده التمركز والتموضع على شارع
صلاح الدين وتقصف هذه المناطق محيط مستشفى
الاقسه عرض الى عده استهدافات من قبل
المدفعيه ايضا ومن قبل الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه وهذا المستشفى الذي بات على
مقربه من ان يخرج من عن الخدمه من جراء
نقص الوقود ونقص المستلزمات ونقص الادويه
في ظل استمرار القصف الاسرائيلي في محيطه
في ظل تمركز الدبابات الاسرائيليه على
اطراف شارعه الاساسي ومنع سيارات الاسعاف
من التوجه الى مخيم المغازي ومخيم البريج
وايضا المناطق الشماليه لمخيم النصيرات
رغم تعرضها للقصف شكرا جزيلا لك هشام زقوت
من رفح وما قلته هو بالتحديد ما قاله
مارتن جريفث وكيل الاين العام للامم
المتحده الذي قال انه لا يوجد مكان امن في
غزه لان الناس يقصفون في الاماكن التي طلب
منهم اللجوء اليها شكرا هشام زقوت من رفح